the Joe Rogan experience what is the
plan in terms of the government means if
they can take out a guy like El Chapo
what is the plan to eradicate all this
and is there really a plan to eradicate
it or is it one of those things where
it's sort of a plan on paper but
realistically they sort of accept the
fact they're never going to get rid of
these people
so I have a like I have a thing like
that like basically cuts out cats at
coatl was a feather chirping and I have
a image of a feathered serpent biting it
sale Mexico has a problem with amnesia a
six-year cycle of amnesia
every person comes in has all these
plans to eradicate the cartels president
goes out nobody likes them anymore new
guy comes in says well I have a better
plan you know and that's the cycle we
always go through so it's a big issue in
Mexico yeah and current currently we
have a leftist president that doesn't
want to have anything to do with the
past administration there are more on
the right of the spectrum his name is
Andres Manuel Lopez Obrador
I'm low vocally supporting Venezuela
that that type of guy apparently he has
a good relationship with the with Trump
that's what's what people say but his
whole thing was abnesti for the cartels
that's a campaign promise amnesty yes
and what does that mean exactly nobody
knows what that means that's what he was
saying that was you have a plan for this
amnesty or is it just like a statement
it was a statement and now if you cede
counter narcotics operations throughout
the country they've the military is not
as active as it used to be whoa
some of the cartels are growing in
influence because of amnesty could be
you know basically I don't see the
efforts that were there when I was
active down there well things change you
know so I don't know IIIi truly think
that the absurd because we're on route
of b2 to having the most violent year in
Mexico as far as cartel related deaths
right when I got out do you wanna had
been on the top most dangerous cities
the planet list and I actually worked
there when it was on the top and through
efforts both before the from the
government and through people like
Lieutenant Colonel a Zola Tiwana was
gone off the list of most dangerous
cities in the world and now it's again
at number one right yeah you sent me
that I was pretty shocked because you
don't hear about that here it's six
murders at night you know I was down
there two days ago and it was
it's basically cartel on cartel so
they're cleaning each other out and just
bodies appear in the morning you know
bridges hung from bridges tortured shot
you know that's you know but again the
there's nobody's doing anything about it
they should you know but kind of turning
a blind eye in a lot of ways
oh and so with this leftist president
this guy with who has this idea of
amnesty the the people that are in
charge of handling the cartel the the
military and the police officers they've
got to feel like a little abandoned yeah
or maybe some of them I'll have a
business plan and they're working at one
side so that's a problem too yeah so so
the people did are nowhere you know we
have a separation of powers down there
as well so the army constitutionally
shouldn't be engaged in combating the
gardels they shouldn't be engaged in
police roles but there were some
amendments done to the Constitution and
you know laws passed but you have to
realize that some of these people that
are fighting the cartels and a policing
type role from the military some of them
can't read right or some of them come
from rural parts of Mexico that
shouldn't they shouldn't be doing that
type of activity so you get a lot of you
know a lot of failures on that side of
the fence we do have some high-level SF
community members in Mexico that are
doing the work but they're few and far
between and then you have the federal
place which has gone through about four
or five name changes in the past you
know ten years because every time though
well not going to call them that changes
uniform because they're all corrupt
Jesus but now there now there this
police right so so they just changed
appearance it changed the name you know
but I got to refresh the public opinion
of it there's a famous uh you know model
investigation federal investigation
please called the ah fee and they were
like modern investigative Federal Police
it's gonna go after and they were
corrupt as hell you know and they all
they did was even get a name change and
all these guys got shuffled around and
living around was like a I know you like
what what no no I'm I'm this now you
know but there's still the same person
who compromised yes yeah so those are
the federal guys right currently they
want to do like a national national
police force and you're like wow they're
gonna get new people they're gonna be
national police force know it's the same
guy change uniform change a hat so
that's on the federal side you know so
we're pretty wanting their state side
each state has their own police force
investigation police force and a
preventive type force and these are
politicized because each state
government may be opposed to the federal
government so there's a there's some
static there and a few and each
municipality has its own police force
and they me it might be completely
different politically than the state and
federal so
[Applause]